es la noticia más esperada en ecuador
son las primeras 8.000 dosis de las
vacunas contra el cob y 19 la primera
entrega de las 86 mil que llegan al país
hasta el mes de marzo estuvimos para
presenciar el momento en que nos dijeron
el mundo cierra
pero también estamos para presenciar el
momento en que vemos llegar la luz
el ecuador es el segundo país en recibir
la vacuna pzifer de américa del sur
hoy empieza el proceso de vacunación en
el ecuador pero con ellas llega también
un gran reto
mantenerlas a la temperatura requerida
menos 70 grados centígrados se usará
hielo seco mientras llegan congeladores
importados de alemania logramos hace una
lanza estratégica para aquí en nuestra
zona distribución colocar 8 congeladores
que almacenan hasta 2 millones de
vacunas los congeladores tienen
temperaturas de menos 80 grados menos 20
y de menos 2 a 8 grados que son lo que
requieren las farmacéuticas son las que
van a traer las vacunas las primeras
dosis llegan cuando se registra un 85
por ciento de ocupación en unidades de
cuidados intensivos a nivel nacional y
sin que exista una estrategia clara de
vacunación según este especialista
nosotros acabamos de publicar un reporte
de los primeros 10.000 pacientes en el
ecuador y pues en base a este estudio
nosotros hemos visto que ciertos grupos
poblacionales tienen menos riesgo de
morir entonces cuando tienes 80 mil
vacunas tú tienes que ver la forma hasta
filosófica y ética de asignar vacunas
escasísimas para una población con
demandas altísimas
las primeras vacunas se distribuirán
entre quito guayaquil y cuenca con ellas
llega un rayo de esperanza puro que por
ahora es tenue pues ecuador necesita
vacunar al 65% de su población